now just before I begin doing this it's
always really important that you start
off looking a question and think how
would I even begin doing this what
strategy my I take what ideas sort of
jump out I have a few ideas I can think
of at least two ways to do this question
I don't know which because I haven't
started yet I don't know which is the
best way does anyone have any ideas at
all how they might begin any thoughts
this is sort of a good sign it's a good
sign that we're doing this question
because we've got to have an idea where
to start
let me give a suggestion see these two
piece of information that begin right
when you see a vertex just like with
linear equations we know there are lots
of ways to state the equation of a
parabola same parabola and I can state
its equation in a variety of different
forms what are the forms is geared
toward the vertex right in fact it's a
form that's on the reference sheet I
don't know if any of you remember it in
a locker Scrabble form it would be
something like this right X - I think
they usually use H squared equals 4a
times y minus K so H and K are going to
be the coordinates of the vertex right
now you do have to be careful because if
we didn't know this then I can't just
state this right away okay in fact I
still need to be careful with it I'll
tell you why in a second if for example
I had changed the question and made the
axis parallel to the x axis right so
this is a sideways parabola it might be
concave left or it might be concave
right how would I change this equation
because this would never give you such a
parabola what would I do to adjust it
yeah very good so if I swap these guys
around if I swap the variables I'll get
a left-right parabola instead of an
up/down okay there is one more thing you
have to be cautious for which is that
and we already just said that H and K
are the coordinates of the vertex
what a very good so it's the focal
length which is why this is your num
it's in locus form so you're talking
about the focal length in the focus and
the directrix it's customary to say that
a is greater than zero because it's a
length okay I have noticed I'm not that
much of a fan of it but it's it's
happened in some of the questions they
actually let a be negative we don't
usually like to do that if we wanted a
parabola that was concave down instead
of making a negative which would do that
we would actually put a minus sign at
the front because we try we're trying
preserve the fact that ace meant to be
elect it's got this quality but anyhow
we can leave that out for now because I
do not know yet whether this will be
concave up or concave down okay so I've
got to start any of these where I might
go from there I mean I can put the
numbers in I can go like this X minus 3
squared a y plus 1 okay I can do that
I've used these two pieces of
information how will I use this I'll use
that so when you see tangent gradient is
a good place for your mind to go but how
will I use that I mean this parabola has
every gradient possible somewhere so
what could I do now one of the things I
love about this topic is this so much of
it is visual a lot of stuff is hard to
like when it's just I like to call it
algebra soup it's like I know it's just
symbols flying around everywhere you
don't have to rely on just as symbols
you can draw yourself a picture and
that's very very instructive so here's
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna try and draw
something like this I don't know what it
looks like exactly I'm gonna try and I'm
also going to draw this because that's
that's obviously quite an important
feature it's not in a form at the moment
that's nice to graph so I'm just gonna
rearrange it ever so slightly if I put
it into slope-intercept form what will
it be it's not that hard very good okay
now I know what that looks like
all right so I'm grab a like a red pen
or whatever I draw me a set of axes and
all this is going to be is a rough
sketch to get a handle on what is going
on a thinking about how we can use that
to solve the question y equals minus 4x
plus 7 where's that going to go minus 4x
plus 7 I would say it's something like
this I guess would you agree with that
that's sort of the shape that you're
getting it's got its if you know it's
its intercept up there at 7 and it's
negative 4 it's very steep ok in the
negative direction when I'm trying to
work out where this parabola is all I
know about it is its vertex in it's in
the direction it's facing so
three negative one fit in this if that's
seven and I've got a gradient of minus
four then I think this coordinate here
is gonna be let me think
seven on four isn't it seven unfor is
like one and a half no one or 3/4 one
two three chords so there's 1 and 3/4
I'm pointing out that it's one in three
quarters because I want to know where it
is in relation to that guy right so
three is is sort of further over so
let's put three around there negative
one won't be all that far down something
like this okay so that guy's the vertex
now this is really really useful because
just by drawing this I now know not just
that it's concave up and down not left
and right
I now know which one it is is it up or
is it down have a look it has to be up
can you see that I didn't actually I
really I literally didn't know that
until I drew that because you can see
like there's no way to draw a concave
down parabola such that this really is a
tangent it didn't have to be concave up
though I could have put the vertex
somewhere else and I would have come to
the opposite conclusion for instance
suppose they had said hey your vertex is
over here if the vertex are there do you
see you can't draw a concave up parabola
it's just gonna it'll blow through that
line there's no way it can be a tangent
okay
so do you see how putting something down
even a rough drawing helps you to reason
through what's going on so good for us
we've got a concave up rather I'm just
gonna draw it so you're Fi do you
something I guess that's fine it's just
there's only meant to be rough sketch
okay
so now I need to set about thinking
about how I use this and this together
to show that to define the exact value
of a that's all it's missing right
all this missing is a